Mich im Urwald zu befinden,
war für mich ein Kulturschock.
Es war unangenehm.
Man ist immer schmutzig
und verschwitzt,
es ist heiss,
und man wird von Mücken zerstochen.
Es gibt so viele Dinge,
die einen stören,
wenn man aus der westlichen
Zivilisation stammt.
Damit hatte ich
anfangs grosse Schwierigkeiten.
Doch nun,
nach diesem ganzen Prozess,
liebe ich es und finde es toll.
Ich sehe das Paradies,
das er immer wieder beschrieben hat.
Das sehe ich jetzt
und ich kann es auch nachempfinden.
Malaysisch Borneo, Juni 2019.
Der Zürcher Filmregisseur
Niklaus Hilber
und sein Produzent Valentin Greutert
durchqueren bei tropischer Hitze
und einer Luftfeuchtigkeit
von fast 90 %
einen der ältesten Urwälder der Erde.
Sie sind bereits
seit Tagen unterwegs.
Ihr Ziel:
ein kleines Dschungeldorf der Penan,
so nennt sich eines der Urvölker
auf Borneo.
Niklaus will den Bewohnern dort
seinen Spielfilm
über Bruno Manser zeigen,
an dem er fast zehn Jahre lang
gearbeitet hat.
Warum reist ein Regisseur
aus der Schweiz um die halbe Welt,
um einem kleinen Urwaldvolk
seinen Film zu zeigen?
* Ruf eines Muezzin *
Limbang, ein paar Tage früher.
Das kleine Städtchen
ist ein letzter Fleck Zivilisation
am Rande dichtesten Dschungels.
Hier treffen Niklaus und Valentin
letzte Vorbereitungen.
Um im Dschungel
eine Leinwand aufbauen zu können,
müssen sie sich zuerst
das nötige Material besorgen.
In einem Geschäft für so allerlei
kaufen sie Metallbeschläge,
Schrauben, Werkzeug und lassen sich
Holz aus der Sägerei bestellen.
Sie haben ja keine Kinos.
Sie können
keinen DVD-Rekorder einschalten
und sich den Film
zu Hause in ihren Hütten anschauen.
Das ist die einzige Art und Weise,
wie sie den Film sehen können.
Das schulden wir ihnen.
Ich finde, es ist eine Sache
der Ehre und des Respekts,
dass man das tut.
Niklaus' Spielfilm
handelt vom Leben des Basler
Umweltaktivisten Bruno Manser,
der in den 80er-Jahren
mit den Penan gegen die Zerstörung
des Regenwaldes gekämpft hat -
und der seit Anfang 2000
verschollen ist.
* Er spricht Penan. *
Der 29-jährige Sven Schelker
verkörpert im Film Manser.
Dabei musste er einen Grossteil
der Dialoge in Penan sprechen lernen.
* Er spricht Penan. *
Es ist, als würde man eine willkür-
liche Zahlenreihe auswendig lernen.
Aber die Penan sagen,
seine Sprache
klinge für sie total authentisch ...
... als ob er
fliessend Penan spräche.
* Er spricht Penan. *
Niklaus wollte seinen Film
unbedingt vor Ort auf Borneo drehen,
mit den richtigen Penan, alles Laien,
die im Film sich selbst verkörpern.
Für mich war von Anfang an klar,
dass ich diesen Film
mit den Penan machen muss.
Es ist ihre Geschichte.
Mit Filipinos,
die auch Englisch sprechen,
wäre es zwar einfacher gewesen,
aber es ist ihre Geschichte.
Es hätte sich
einfach seltsam angefühlt,
wenn es nicht sie gewesen wären.
Wenn ich hier zurückblicke,
denke ich: "Wow ..."
"Das war ja total idyllisch ..."
"... toll und abenteuerlich."
Aber in der Erinnerung
habe ich es nicht so abgespeichert.
Das ist eigentlich seltsam.
Hast du ein Taschenmesser, Valentin?
Im Hotelzimmer
testen die beiden das Equipment,
das sie z.T. hier gekauft, z.T.
aus der Schweiz mitgebracht haben.
Es ist eingeschaltet.
Ich glaube, es funktioniert, oder?
Geh mal dorthin und zieh daran!
Mal sehen, ob es elastisch ist.
Wir müssen es gut befestigen,
damit es hält.
Wenn starker Wind wehen sollte ...
... was abends
manchmal der Fall ist,
müssen wir die Vorführung
möglicherweise unterbrechen.
Ich denke,
der Wind ist unser grösster Feind.
Hello.
- Hi.
Hey, James.
- Hey.
Ein paar von Niklaus'
Hauptdarstellern treffen ein.
Sie werden ihn und Valentin
zur Premiere begleiten.
How are you?
And Elisabeth. Where is she?
Hi.
Everything good? - Yes.
- Did you have a safe trip?
Man trifft sich
zum gemeinsamen Abendessen,
um die lange und strapaziöse Reise
zu besprechen.
So, if we leave at eight,
we get there at four o'clock,
including the two hours
for stop-and-go? - Yeah.
Ebenfalls dazugekommen
ist Produktionsmanager Eric
und ein Penan-Englisch-Übersetzer.
In one day, we go from Gitta ...
... Tevenga ...
Die Reise beginnt mit einer
beschwerlichen Fahrt auf endlosen,
staubtrockenen Naturstrassen,
die die Holzfällerfirmen
in den Dschungel geschlagen haben.
* Rockmusik aus dem Autoradio *
Es geht tief hinein in den Urwald
zu Peng Megut.
Peng habe ich 2012 kennengelernt,
als ich anlässlich
einer Recherchereise
zum ersten Mal hier war.
Er lebte damals
noch so wie in den alten Zeiten,
also in der Zeit, als Bruno
hier war, und bevor man begann,
hier systematisch
den Regenwald abzuholzen.
Mich interessiert es, ob er
das Nomadenleben weiterhin lebt
und wie es bei ihm aussieht.
Der Grund
für unseren Besuch ist jedoch,
dass ich ihn wahnsinnig gern
zu unserem Screening einladen würde.
Ich hoffe,
dass er nach Long Gitta mitkommen
und sich den Film anschauen kann.
Nach sechsstündiger Fahrt versperrt
plötzlich eine Hütte den Weg.
Die Penan haben sie als Blockade
direkt auf die Strasse gebaut,
um die Holzfäller an der Zerstörung
ihres Lebensraums zu hindern -
so wie damals mit Bruno Manser.
Hier werden Niklaus und sein Team
von Peng und seiner Sippe empfangen.
Hello.
* Niklaus spricht Penan. *
How are you?
- Hello.
This is, ähm ...
... when Bruno
was bitten by a snake.
* Der Übersetzter spricht Penan. *
Niklaus zeigt Peng und seinen Leuten
Fotos von den Dreharbeiten.
Peng hat Bruno selbst gut gekannt.
Er erzählt, er hätte ihm damals
das Blasrohrschiessen beigebracht.
Sie seien zusammen in den Wald
gegangen und hätten Vögel gejagt.
Niklaus wird von Pengs Nachbar
Igu Agan in seine Hütte eingeladen.
Er möchte ihm unbedingt
auch ein paar Fotos zeigen.
Es sind Bilder von seiner Familie.
His wife passed away.
Seine Frau und sein Vater
sind mittlerweile beide verstorben.
Wie hat Niklaus die Rückkehr
zu Peng nach sieben Jahren erlebt?
Zum einen fiel mir auf,
dass es viel weniger Familien sind.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass damals sieben
oder acht Familien hier waren.
Nun sind es noch drei.
Andererseits sieht man auch,
dass sich ein grösserer Einfluss
der modernen Welt breitmacht.
Im Gespräch zeigte sich auch,
dass sie eigentlich
gar nicht mehr nomadisierend leben,
sondern semi-nomadisierend,
wie sie es nennen.
D.h., hier ist ihre Basis, an
die sie immer wieder zurückkommen.
Sie gehen
für ein paar Tage in den Wald,
bauen sich
dort eine Schutzhütte, jagen
und kommen danach
wieder hierher zurück.
Sie leben eigentlich stationär.
* Grillenzirpen, leise Gespräche *
Unterwegs nach Long Gitta,
wo in zwei Tagen
die Filmpremiere stattfinden soll.
Warum hat sich Niklaus
ausgerechnet diesen Ort
für seine Premiere ausgesucht?
Long Gitta war der Ort,
an dem sich Bruno
in den Anfangsjahren oft aufhielt.
Das ist auch der Ort,
von dem Along Sega stammt.
Along Sega
ist eine wichtige Figur im Film.
Er spielt Brunos Ziehvater.
Das war auch in der Realität so.
Er adoptierte ihn am Ende sogar.
Darum dachte ich, das sei
der beste Ort für unsere Premiere.
Die Truppe gelangt an einen Fluss,
wo sie von Booten abgeholt wird,
die sie nach Long Gitta
bringen sollen.
Der Wasserstand ist niedrig,
und die Boote laufen
immer wieder auf Grund auf.
Kurz vor Long Gitta werden sie
jedoch unerwartet am Ufer abgeladen.
Und dann sind auf einmal die meisten
der Penan-Begleiter verschwunden.
Der Grund wird sich später klären.
Erstmal müssen sie das letzte
Wegstück allein zurücklegen.
* Gesang *
(Niklaus) Ah, wow.
Die Penan wollten den Regisseur
und sein Team gebührend empfangen -
deshalb das Vorauseilen
der Begleiter.
* Er spricht Penan. *
Thank you.
Selai, here. Selai.
Sie werden von jedem einzelnen
der Anwesenden begrüsst,
begleitet von Trommeln und Tanz.
* Rhythmische Trommelschläge,
Gesang *
* Jauchzen *
* Rhythmische Trommelschläge *
Es berührt mich sehr, dass
so viele Leute aus der ganzen Region
den Weg auf sich genommen haben,
um hierherzukommen.
Ich weiss, wie schwer es ist,
im Dschungel von einem Ort
zum anderen zu gelangen.
Ich fühle mich sehr geehrt.
Und vielen Dank
für diesen wundervollen Empfang.
Das haben wir nicht erwartet.
Wir sahen nur,
wie einige wegschlichen,
und hatten keine Ahnung warum.
Das war eine grosse Überraschung
für uns. Es war wundervoll.
Vielen herzlichen Dank.
* Er bedankt sich auf Penan. *
Hey!
* Applaus *
Am nächsten Tag
beginnen Niklaus und Valentin
mit den Vorbereitungen
für die Premiere.
Die Penan helfen tatkräftig mit.
Ich bin definitiv sehr gespannt,
wie sie auf das Bild reagieren
werden, das der Film vermittelt.
Man muss natürlich bedenken,
dass das Brunos Bild ist.
Der Film ist über Bruno Manser,
und wir bleiben
Brunos Sichtweise sehr treu.
* Spannende Musik *
Es ist genau so,
wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe:
Open-Air-Kino im Urwald.
Ich hoffe, dass die Leinwand stabil
ist, wenn sie aufgespannt ist,
dass sie nicht schwingt und
dass das Bild nicht verzerrt wird.
Aber bis jetzt ... So far so good.
Aber dann taucht doch noch
ein gravierendes Problem auf.
Der Stromgenerator im Dorf
entpuppt sich als viel zu laut
und muss so weit vom Projektor
entfernt platziert werden,
dass Valentin rund 40 m
Verlängerungskabel fehlen.
Wir stellen den Generator mal auf,
schalten ihn ein und schauen,
wo er am wenigsten laut ist.
Dann prüfen wir,
wie viele Meter Kabel wir haben
und was wir noch brauchen.
Wenn er nicht am Fluss hinten steht,
hört man ihn extrem gut.
Jetzt gilt es,
im Dorf Kabel zu finden -
keine einfache Aufgabe
hier draussen im Dschungel.
You can get something like this.
* Ein Mann spricht Penan. *
Ah, das ist Draht.
Das erste Angebot
entpuppt sich als unbrauchbar.
Es ist Draht, kein Stromkabel.
This is no power cable.
Ich weiss gar nicht,
was ich tun soll.
Wenn es kein Kabel gibt,
gibt es kein Kabel.
Die Zeit drängt.
Die Penan sind bereits
mitten in den Festvorbereitungen.
In der Zwischenzeit
tragen die Bewohner zusammen,
was sie an Kabelresten finden.
Wir hoffen,
dass kein Elektriker zuschaut.
Es funktioniert:
Die Verbindung steht.
Ich finde es toll.
Wir sind hier mitten im Urwald
in Bornea, am Ende der Welt
und zeigen einen Film
über einen Schweizer,
der mit diesem Publikum ...
... gegen die Abholzung
des Regenwaldes kämpfte.
Super. Das schönste Kino.
Die Zuschauer
nehmen im Dschungelkino Platz.
Einige von ihnen sehen zum ersten Mal
in ihrem Leben einen Film.
Willkommen zum ersten
Long-Gitta-Dschungelkino.
* Er übersetzt auf Penan. *
Dieser Film ist das Resultat
von Bruno Mansers
tiefer Verbindung mit den Penan.
Diese Vorführung ist der Endpunkt
einer langen Reise
von Valentin und mir.
Diese Reise war geprägt
von vielen herzerwärmenden
und freudigen Erlebnissen,
v.a. weil sich die Penan
an der Realisierung dieses Projekts
beteiligten.
Mit dieser Vorführung ist
diese Reise zu einem Ende gekommen,
und Valentin und ich
übergeben euch diesen Film.
In wenigen Minuten
können wir beginnen. Viel Vergnügen.
* Mystische Klänge aus dem Film *
* Im Film spricht ein Mann Penan. *
(Im Film) To be happy,
all they require is a full belly
and a peaceful environment.
Über 2 Std. verfolgen die Zuschauer
gebannt ihre eigene Geschichte.
Die Betroffenheit
ist förmlich greifbar.
Ich blickte immer wieder mal
nach hinten und sah,
dass sie total gefesselt waren.
Das ist das schönste Gefühl
für einen Regisseur.
Ähm, ja, super.
Ich bin erleichtert, dass es
nicht zu regnen begonnen hat.
Ich sah im Hintergrund immer Blitze,
aber das Wetter blieb stabil.
Und, ja ...
Ich bin selbst noch total ...
... im Film gefangen.
Ihre Geschichte
ist sehr traumatisch.
Sie wurden
zur Sesshaftigkeit gezwungen.
Dass sie das so sehen
und dass sie durch den Film
damit konfrontiert wurden,
ist einfach stark.
Äh, also, ich finde ...
... es hat sich mehr als gelohnt.
Ich würde diesen Aufwand
sofort wieder betreiben.
Es war überhaupt kein Aufwand.
Beim gemeinsamen Essen
sind die meisten
zu Beginn still in ihren Gedanken.
Der Film wirkt offensichtlich nach.
Dann erhalten die Schauspieler
und das Team
für die Filmvorführung ein Geschenk.
* Applaus *
Später beginnt man,
sich über den Film auszutauschen.
Die Gespräche
dauern bis tief in die Nacht.
Am nächsten Morgen fasst Niklaus
für uns die Gespräche zusammen.
Die jüngere Generation
war sehr fasziniert davon,
wie wir diese Kleidung,
diese Kostüme hergestellt haben
und dass es so echt aussah.
Das gefiel ihnen sehr.
Peng sagte z.B.
etwas ganz Interessantes:
In einer Szene
stand Bruno vor der Blockade.
Peng meinte, dass ihn die Penan
nie vorn hätten stehen lassen,
wo er hätte verhaftet werden können.
Sie hätten ihn
immer im Gebüsch versteckt.
Er befürchtet,
dass die Penan deswegen
im Film schlecht dastehen,
weil sie Bruno
quasi der Gefahr aussetzen.
Das fand ich sehr spannend.
Das schönste Statement
stammte von Along Sengas Frau.
Sie sagte - sehr poetisch -, wenn
dieser Film einen Schatten hätte,
würde sie ihn einfangen
und mitnehmen wollen.
Es wäre natürlich schön,
wenn der Film den Penan
in ihrem Kampf helfen würde.
Es ist ja
eine Geschichte mit offenem Ende.
Es ist alles noch im Gang.
Der Regenwald
wird weiterhin abgeholzt und ...
... es geht ihnen
nicht besser als zuvor.
Es wäre natürlich toll,
wenn dieser Film
auf irgendeine Art und Weise
ein Bewusstsein
für das Ganze schaffen könnte,
damit es für sie
etwas leichter wird.
Aber das sind natürlich
gewisse Fantasien von mir.
Niklaus und sein Team
machen sich auf die Rückreise.
Wie die Geschichte für die Penan
weitergeht, ist ungewiss.